hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the crate
work ok you're probably going I this
isn't where we you was no it's not
because as one of you mentioned I needed
to do that I needed to do that so I
don't know why I was able to go into the
next area without that because what
happened was I was able to get out of
that little room but I was unable to get
back to the prison the door was locked
so um haha just a little bit of an
oversight for the guy I don't know what
that did besides infusing the dagger
with Elco hest
there's a grunt here I forgot about you
Oh
balls balls that's a rock I can't do
anything with a rock pause I'll just
have to go around you you want to step
oh yeah yeah I'm in there hey you so
stupid and dumb and ugly to not like me
who is both Oh what the are you doing
haha yeah I'm in there I'm the greatest
ok I think I go this way
I'm so awesome in every way
I'm so great I'm so great I'm so great
I'm so great okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah wait what yeah okay so I know
exactly where to go so I'm gonna get
there and I'm gonna get down there now
I'm gonna get done quickly cuz I've
already cut out a little bit that's how
you get I'm grateful the sacrifices that
I have made for this game there's this
fine game that's just kidding I love
each and every one of you get the other
one two pieces of orb Oh big baby
Oh tied to a table you don't wanna die
oh no maybe if you don't know I didn't
know whatever would happen if I put the
other orbital oh oh that's how they
created the monsters
I don't like that knocking
seriously of all the potential creepy
things they men have gave that knocking
was probably one of the most disturbing
I had ever encountered like no joke it
was like in the last episode I was
unbelievably terrified that was like the
worst thing I'd ever encountered because
it's just something messing with your
mind cuz you know in amnesia what the
hell could okay I got a new wallpaper by
the way and it's just kind of staring at
me in the face
I have creepy wallpapers to tie to try
to help me get it
immersed in the atmosphere so get it
atmosphere
let's kill this [ __ ] ha ha
okay that's confusing because I was able
to pick it up before there must have
been some way to get back to the prison
level by either way suck it down you
piece of [ __ ] I hate you so much
you stupid new my it's locked cuz that
monster didn't bash it down so uh I
guess that's it then okay what did uh
what did that what did that what did it
do what did that do I actually didn't
take very much time so I'm glad I'm able
to move forward now what did what did
that do it lurked it's locked
what did that do I don't even know did I
miss any like Boyle or something
important I don't think I did maybe a
tinderbox no look [ __ ] nothing okay I
think I might've missed like one oh and
a bucket of oil I know where the oil is
I'm gonna get yo oil the oil here no
this isn't any oil is is where the
tender box is and there's where the
letter is said I should probably read
and this is where the lantern is that I
supposedly should pick up okay blah blah
blah blah blah
and then there's a loud downer dumb in
here ya see my memory is working for me
no I killed you yeah
that is not a Bob that's a goodness
that's a cultist
what is he doing here what are you doing
here those are the second new monsters
okay okay okay okay okay I didn't get my
oil you son of a [ __ ] I'll take you on
yeah I got dagger too you want to step
on thing so you want to step you sound
weird
a beast damage daba daba wow you look
- family holiday where did you cover up
did you open a door doo doo doo doo doo
doo de doo you dead you dead you're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
better hold my breath one
I hear that what the what the what am I
supposed to do what am I supposed to do
who are they still out there are they
still there yeah I see him huh oh you
sir head in the closet sir closet in
here to hide in no there's not oh don't
slam don't slam don't slam don't slam
don't slap it's Little Miss Phinney
bunny motivates fettuccine alfredo the
hell are they saying some sort of chance
[Applause]
it sounds like they'll do i do what do i
do I gotta get to fit I got to get to
like the elevator maybe maybe the
elevators down here now I don't know I
don't know they're all over the place
they're everywhere and nowhere
no they're everywhere just everywhere
okay so if he's I see him
yep there is okay if he's coming this
way
I'll give them a some red herring all
the store is gone what do i do what do i
do what do i do what i do what do i do
uh there is nothing there's nothing it
can't be done they're gonna get me
they're gonna eat my niblets off why why
can't they just leave me alone
Oh kill their best friends I'm so sorry
oh and they're quick oh they come up
fast Anya I just got to get behind this
pile of boxes they'll never know they'll
never ever know I'm here
see all of a day oh my go [ __ ] yourself
huh they'll never know
[Music]
Mercy's gonna stay here everybody be
quiet
everybody be quiet out there don't say
we
[Music]
I should find the shard
I heard them open the gate are they
gonna go away door is still intact
oh man
[Music]
okay I think I can make a break for it
I'm a hiding place about a place to
sweat away okay I gotta make a break for
it I gotta make a break for it okay yes
yes yes yes huh
it had been many years since he touched
a shard but as soon as his finger
stroked it he felt the V of the orbs
lingering warmth he lifted it from its
pedestal for whatever reason the shadow
had spared him he had to proceed with
caution ha ha ha oh man
oh that was bad that's bad
ah I can smash things too
what's in there huh dinner a vat of
birds smack Oh scream come on give me
some oil man give me some oil I don't
have much oil I didn't get a chance to
grab the oil I was in that other room
you're all uh holes every one of EA is n
a hole capital a hole what the hell Oh
vodka that's done same right what am i
oh oh uh what okay never mind let's just
keep going
this way maybe I'm gonna run out of oil
real quick there's some in there you
were hiding me from me for me what's in
there huh
some special can move these boxes I'm
too wimpy what's down there what's down
there
hi my Britta more I have to find it all
the way across okay
suddenly I can't run as fast isn't that
weird like the torches all go out by the
torches agua
was a complete success what was what was
a complete success your I can't even
think of something clever right now no
oil none for me I am oil this oh man I
think that everyone should because I am
out of oil
everyone [ __ ] whoa hello everyone should
take the time out of their day to lather
themselves up with baby oil in my honor
because I am not fortunate enough to
have oil
ergo those of you who do have oil must
use it to help me by slathering yourself
up with baby oil
hello baby hey how you doing oh man
you're a sight for sore eyes oh boy um
I've had the worst day baby I've had the
worst day it's just been non-stop
diabolical demons trying to get my
niblets and you know my niblets are only
for you baby
oh man okay is there anything in here
huh see anything okay hi we're good
we're good let's just close the door and
I'm all out of time so you know men Emma
yeah my baby here are gonna pop some
quality time together
get away from the demons for a little
bit so you all need to scram so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see
in the next video by
[Music]